Jake: 拍一个跟他们斗舞
Jake: Let's shoot a video dancing against them.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 跟他们斗舞
Jake: Dance battle with them.
Jake: 斗是什么
Jake: What does "battle" mean?
Lucia: 好厉害啊
Lucia: So impressive.
Tasha: 就是有一个棍子拼控制另一根棍子
Tasha: It's like using one stick to control another stick.
Alice: 能玩一下吗
Alice: Can we try it?
Lucia: 啊这个好想玩
Lucia: Ah, I really want to play this.
Jake: 花棍
Jake: Flower stick.
Alice: 花棍
Alice: Flower stick.
Jake: 像是那种打打扫厕所呵
Jake: Like the ones used to clean toilets, huh.
Jake: 呵是
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake: 这练多久啊
Jake: How long do you practice?
Jake: 能能练这样
Jake: Can you practice to this level?
其他人：你们练快
Others: You all practice quickly.
其他人： 有个十天半个月
Others: About ten days to half a month.
Jake: 半个月半个月就会玩了
Jake: Half a month and you can play it.
其他人：对像你们练快
Others: Yes, you all learn quickly.
其他人：我们上岁数的就慢了
Others: We older ones learn slower.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 我们能试一下吗
Alice: Can we try it?
Jake: 哈哈谢谢您
Jake: Haha, thank you.
Alice: 谢谢怎怎怎么发力呢
Alice: Thank you. How do you exert force?
Jake: 要要要不哎
Jake: You, you, wait.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake: 哈哈绕了3圈挺厉害
Jake: Haha, you spun it three times, very impressive.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: I'm dying of laughter.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice: 我发现转不起来
Alice: I can't seem to spin it.
Alice: 我能看下你是怎么开始的吗
Alice: Can I see how you start it?
其他人：这不是拿下来就会
Others: You just pick it up and you know.
Jake: 好离谱的数据我靠
Jake: Such ridiculous data, wow.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 这样写来的
Alice: This is how it's written.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 迫不及待哦
Tasha: Can't wait.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: So impressive.
Alice: 哦这样起来的
Alice: Oh, that's how it starts.
Alice: 哦哦行
Alice: Oh, okay.
Alice: 太牛了
Alice: So amazing.
其他人：这个这样调调调整
Others: Adjust it like this.
其他人：选个中心就行
Others: Just pick a center.
其他人：选个中心
Others: Pick a center.
Alice: 我能使两个棍弄起来吗
Alice: Can I get two sticks to work together?
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Jake: 你厉害
Jake: You're impressive.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 这毛
Jake: This fur...
Jake: 这自怎么自己做的
Jake: How did you make this yourself?
Jake: 外边买
Jake: Bought from outside?
其他人：开始i也是买的现在我自己做我在卖
Others: I used to buy it, but now I make it myself and sell it.
Jake: 哦哦哦也卖哦
Jake: Oh, oh, you sell it too.
Jake: 要不咱两个扔试试
Jake: How about we both try throwing it?
Jake: 哎呦厉害
Jake: Wow, impressive.
其他人：一个你还弄不成呢两个的比一个的难度大多了
Others: You can't even handle one, two sticks are much harder.
Jake: 这两个棍
Jake: These two sticks...
Jake: 两两两个棍两个棍
Jake: Two, two sticks, two sticks.
Jake: 两个棍容易一点
Jake: Two sticks are a bit easier.
其他人：这个你就看看热闹你要打算学这个得从基础学起
Others: Just watch for fun, if you want to learn, you need to start from the basics.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah!
Jake: 转起来了
Jake: It's spinning.
Jake: 就刚刚刚刚那一段
Jake: Just that part earlier.
Jake: 然后就重复剪出来
Jake: Then just repeat and cut it out.
Jake: 重复你就一直转
Jake: Repeat and keep spinning.
Jake: 哈哈哈GIF出来了
Jake: Hahaha, make it a GIF.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Jake: 够剪了够剪了够剪了
Jake: Enough to cut, enough to cut.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Katrina:  走吧下一个景
Katrina: Let's go, next scene.
Jake: 走吧下一个
Jake: Let's go, next one.
Jake: 我们最后转到原来的位置
Jake: We'll end up back where we started.
Jake: 这样整个公园就重建出来了
Jake: This way we'll reconstruct the whole park.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice: 啊差不多就围湖一圈
Alice: Oh, almost a circle around the lake.
Tasha: 他哥就
Tasha: His brother just...
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 这个小亭子还挺凉快的通风
Alice: This little pavilion is quite cool and breezy.
Jake: 对这亭子挺好
Jake: Yeah, this pavilion is nice.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 噢那个那个上面黏黏的
Alice: Oh, that part is sticky.
Alice: 他就增加那个粘性
Alice: It increases the stickiness.
Lucia: 啊摩擦摩擦力吗
Lucia: Oh, friction force?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Alice: 嗯就那个皮上面有那个黏黏的油
Alice: Yeah, there's sticky oil on the skin
Jake: 哦哦
Jake: Oh oh
Jake: 妙啊
Jake: Brilliant
Katrina:  哎呦
Katrina: Oh my
Alice: 搓一下吧
Alice: Give it a rub
Jake: 湖水洗一洗
Jake: Wash it in the lake
Alice: 太太臭了哈哈
Alice: It's so stinky haha
Shure: 还好有这个事顶一下
Shure: Good thing we have this to cover
Shure: 不然话就会被骂
Shure: Or else we'd get scolded
Katrina:  也可以往里走哎
Katrina: We can go inside too
Alice: 禁止钓鱼
Alice: No fishing allowed
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 虽然有很多环卫工人
Jake: Even though there are many sanitation workers
Lucia: 可能他有点富营养化吧
Lucia: Maybe it's a bit eutrophic
Tasha: 好专业啊
Tasha: So professional
Jake: 是的专业
Jake: Yes, professional
Lucia: 啊没有
Lucia: Ah, not really
Lucia: 我乱说的
Lucia: I was just making it up
Lucia: 就是因为它有点发绿
Lucia: It's because it's a bit green
Lucia: 然后又有泡泡
Lucia: And has bubbles
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 或许地理课上吗
Lucia: Maybe in geography class?
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Could be
Jake: 可以绕啊
Jake: We can go around
Jake: 只要绕过去就行
Jake: Just need to go around it
Shure:  你带了头盔
Shure: You have a helmet
Shure:  可是没有插上
Shure: But it's not plugged in
Jake: 一会再插
Jake: I'll plug it in later
Jake: 刚刚其实应该插一下
Jake: Should've plugged it in just now
Jake: 他一次只能录25分钟
Jake: It can only record for 25 minutes
Jake: 我要找到25分钟的那个时间段
Jake: I need to find the 25-minute segment
Jake: 刚刚那段其实挺好的忘了
Jake: The last part was actually pretty good, forgot
Jake: 看下一段
Jake: Let's see the next part
Alice: 这颜色好漂亮
Alice: This color is so pretty
Tasha: 这个树吗
Tasha: This tree?
Alice: 对呀
Alice: Yeah
Tasha: 鸡爪7哦
Tasha: Chicken feet tree
Alice: 好漂亮好漂亮
Alice: So pretty, so pretty
Jake: 叫啥呀
Jake: What's it called?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah?
Jake: 叫什么呀
Jake: What's it called?
Jake: 鸡爪7 鸡爪7
Jake: Chicken claw 7, chicken claw 7.
Tasha: 爪7
Tasha: Claw 7.
Tasha: 是的他长得像鸡爪子一样
Tasha: Yeah, it looks like a chicken claw.
Jake: 好想吃啊
Jake: I really want to eat it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah?
Jake: 也想吃
Jake: I want to eat it too.
Tasha: 那我给你摘一片你吃吧
Tasha: Then I'll pick a piece for you to eat.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我还以为打开方式是
Lucia: I thought we were opening it like this.
Lucia: 我们晚上吃鸡爪呢
Lucia: We're having chicken claws for dinner.
Jake: 呵呵是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's what it means.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 呵呵来给我试叶子可能是
Jake: Haha, come try the leaf, maybe it's...
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Shure:  我说我说这里面有蛤蟆叫了
Shure: I think I hear a frog croaking.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah?
Shure:  听到了蟾蜍的叫声
Shure: I heard a toad croaking.
Shure:  稍微践踏一下
Shure: Just step on it a bit.
Jake: 找手串呢
Jake: Looking for the beads.
Shure:  我听到了
Shure: I heard it.
Jake: 找蛤蟆了
Jake: Looking for the toad.
Shure:  听取蛙声一片
Shure: Listening to the sound of frogs all around.
Alice: 从这走过去
Alice: Walk through here.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 比谁走得快
Jake: Let's see who can walk faster.
Jake: 到那个呃真的走
Jake: Let's really walk to that...
Lucia: 不行底下都有水
Lucia: No way, there's water everywhere.
Lucia: 没有落脚点
Lucia: No place to step.
Tasha: 很滑的
Tasha: It's very slippery.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 掉进去了的话
Lucia: If you fall in...
Jake: 这个
Jake: This...
Lucia: AI就会捕获人类早期落水宝贵纪录
Lucia: AI will capture the precious record of humans falling into the water.
Jake: 是这是他捕捉的最后一个信号
Jake: Yes, this will be its last captured signal.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 哦然后进水就坏了是吗
Jake: 对
Alice: AI能不能理解我们为什么非要从这走
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 他就最后总结出人类都太不理性了
Lucia: 然后决定消灭人类吗
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 我看了好多类似的科幻片哈哈
Jake: 哦是吧
Tasha: 桃花潭水
Shure:  go
Shure:  前面这条是京杭大运河
Jake: 哪一条啊
Tasha: 真的吗潜在的这条河
Tasha: 我们就可以回家了阿sir
Jake: 对
Jake: 确实
Jake: 那你的那个手链在杭州可以能找到
Shure: 你怎么知道我过段要去杭州
Shure: How did you know I'm going to Hangzhou soon?
Jake: 那你去找找
Jake: Then you should go check it out.
Jake: 先录一段
Jake: Let's record a bit first.
Alice: 晚上在这应该挺舒服
Alice: It should be pretty nice here at night.
Alice: 晚上逛公园很舒服
Alice: Strolling in the park at night is really pleasant.
Jake: 贴了一个符就防虫了上面
Jake: Just sticking a charm on it keeps the bugs away.
Tasha: 无法从吊带上下来
Tasha: Can't get down from the harness.
Jake: 哦这么好这
Jake: Oh, that's really good.
Tasha: 然后就死在树上
Tasha: Then it just dies on the tree.
Tasha: 当然你相信了吗
Tasha: Of course, do you believe it?
Jake: 我信
Jake: I believe.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 李李卓吾
Jake: Li Zhuowu.
Jake: 李卓吾墓
Jake: Li Zhuowu's tomb.
Jake: 一个墓地
Jake: A cemetery.
Jake: 虽然不知道是谁
Jake: Though I don't know who he is.
Jake: 墓地
Jake: Cemetery.
Tasha: 墓地
Tasha: Cemetery.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Alice: 这有个坟包
Alice: There's a burial mound here.
Tasha: 哦天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Alice: 这公园是不是就是为他建的
Alice: Was this park built just for him?
Tasha: 李治好像
Tasha: Li Zhi, it seems like.
Jake: 不止吧刚刚好像看到别
Jake: Not only that, I think I just saw some...
Jake: 的目的好像是
Jake: The purpose seems to be...
Alice: 原来是个大墓园啊
Alice: So it’s actually a big cemetery?
Jake: 嗯哼可以是或者是原来有一个公园
Jake: Hmm, it could be, or maybe it used to be a park.
Jake: 然后谁想埋着埋一下
Jake: And then someone decided to bury here.
Jake: 住附近的埋一下
Jake: People living nearby just bury here.
Alice: 像海棠海棠啊
Alice: Like crabapple, crabapple trees.
Alice: 已经过了观赏季了
Alice: The blooming season is already over.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Katrina:  我不是那样的人
Katrina: I'm not that kind of person.
Alice: 最多看看郁金香估计就
Alice: At most, we can see tulips, I guess.
Tasha: 哪有郁金香
Tasha: Where are the tulips?
Alice: 我说这个季节
Alice: I mean this season.
Alice: 然后要牡丹之类的
Alice: And then peonies or something like that.
Shure:  向我徐徐走过来
Shure: Walking slowly towards me.
Shure:  你好害怕
Shure: You’re so scared.
Shure:  你好可怕呀
Shure: You’re so scary.
Jake: 为啥呀我这一棒槌下去是吧
Jake: Why? If I swing this club down, right?
Shure:  就是就是就是
Shure: Exactly, exactly, exactly.
Shure:  一脸严肃
Shure: With a serious face.
Shure:  然后肩膀就这样走回
Shure: And then walking back with your shoulders like that.
Shure:  我爬山
Shure: I’m climbing the mountain.
Jake: 来爬山这是什么山
Jake: Come on, what mountain is this?
Alice: 魏明山
Alice: Weiming Mountain.
Lucia: 陡坡路华山
Lucia: Steep slope, Huashan.
Katrina:  情人坡
Katrina: Lover’s Slope.
Jake:陡坡路滑山好嘞
Jake: Steep slope, slippery mountain, okay.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不知道是哪几个字有诗意的呢哈哈
Lucia: Don’t know which poetic words to use, haha.
Jake: 是是是一个华山
Jake: It’s, it’s, it’s Huashan.
Jake: 简称华山
Jake: Also known as Huashan.
Jake: 我们在爬华山
Jake: We’re climbing Huashan.
Jake: 香山哈哈哈哈嘿
Jake: Xiangshan, hahaha, hey.
Lucia: 华北指定香山
Lucia: Northern China’s designated Xiangshan.
Katrina:  没见过紫丁香
Katrina: Never seen lilac.
Katrina:  那白的呢
Katrina: What about the white ones?
Alice: 白丁香
Alice: White lilac
Katrina:  白丁香
Katrina: White lilac
Katrina:  转弯
Katrina: Turn here
Jake: 这怎么有个小洞
Jake: Why is there a small hole here?
Jake: 小门
Jake: Small door
Lucia: 那里有个瞭望塔
Lucia: There's a lookout tower over there
Lucia: 呃就是就是这个
Lucia: Uh, it's, it's this one
Jake: 哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, oh
Lucia: 本来想说瞭望台的嘴瓢啊
Lucia: I meant to say lookout platform, slipped my tongue
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 你说瞭望塔往上看
Jake: You said lookout tower, look up
Lucia: sorry
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 习惯了
Lucia: I'm used to it
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 没有就是我
Lucia: No, it's just me
Jake: 打打一局是吧哈哈
Jake: Let's play a round, right? Haha
Lucia: 我经常看的一个作品
Lucia: It's from a work I often watch
Lucia: 里面有一个基地叫这个名字
Lucia: There's a base in it with that name
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 这到公路了
Jake: We've reached the highway
Jake: 能开车了
Jake: We can drive now
Jake: 这是出园了吗
Jake: Have we left the park?
Jake: 还是啥意思
Jake: Or what does this mean?
Jake: 这小台阶挺好
Jake: This little step is nice
Alice: 梯田
Alice: Terraces
Katrina:  发光发丝
Katrina: Shining hair
Katrina:  就应该这时间点的阳光
Katrina: It must be the sunlight at this time
Alice: 雷峰塔
Alice: Leifeng Pagoda
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哦原来这塔不在这里边
Lucia: Oh, so the tower isn't here
Jake: 可以过去吧
Jake: Can we go over there?
Jake: 问问问
Jake: Let's ask
Jake: 问看看
Jake: Let's ask around
Jake: 这有个地图倒是可以看看
Jake: There's a map here, we can check it out
Jake: 哎咱在哪啊
Jake: Hey, where are we?
Alice: 您的位置
Alice: Your location
Jake: 在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Lucia: 这个有一个小星号的地方
Lucia: It's this place with a small star
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one
Lucia: 您在这里
Lucia: You're here.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 过一个我就看到
Tasha: I saw it just now.
Tasha: 我刚刚想买但你们都走远了
Tasha: I wanted to buy it, but you all walked away.
Katrina:  什么东西啊
Katrina: What was it?
Katrina:  就是售货机里有一个饮料
Katrina: There was a drink in the vending machine.
Katrina:  我还挺想买的哦哦哦
Katrina: I really wanted to buy it, oh oh oh.
Tasha: 我刚刚看你想买你们都走了
Tasha: I saw you wanted to buy it, but you all left.
Tasha: 然后我在那
Tasha: And then I was there.
Katrina:  没事你喊我们就行
Katrina: It's fine, just call us next time.
Lucia: 哪里
Lucia: Where?
Jake: 哦售货机
Jake: Oh, the vending machine.
Alice: 下次再遇到我就买
Alice: I'll buy it next time I see it.
Jake: 好一会转
Jake: Okay, turn around later.
Jake: 转到最后的这个地方
Jake: Turn to the last place.
Jake: 然后再多走一段
Jake: And then walk a bit further.
Shure:  我只想要瓶水
Shure: I just want a bottle of water.
Shure:  自己的生日
Shure: For my birthday.
Tasha: 那个桃子饮料汁
Tasha: That peach juice.
Tasha: 我当时在想他是冰的还是常温的
Tasha: I was wondering if it's cold or room temperature.
Jake: 游
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 游客中心是吗
Jake: The visitor center, right?
Jake: 还是会有卖的
Jake: They should have it there.
Tasha: 然后我开始人脸识别发现识别不上啊
Tasha: Then I tried face recognition but it didn't work.
Jake: 卖水的地方
Jake: The place that sells water.
Lucia: 好像是一个
Lucia: Seems like it.
Katrina:  刚进来的地方
Katrina: The place we just came in.
Tasha: 然后开始拿支付宝
Tasha: Then I switched to Alipay.
Lucia: 他们说是一个
Lucia: They said it was there.
Lucia: 那个自动售货机
Lucia: That vending machine.
Tasha: 我发现你们已经走了
Tasha: I realized you all had left.
Katrina:  我们在哪呢
Katrina: Where are we?
Katrina:  从这进来的吧
Katrina: We came in from here, right?
Katrina:  这样绕一圈
Katrina: Like this, make a loop.
Katrina:  还是这这吧
Katrina: Or maybe this way.
Jake: 可能是西边
Jake: It might be to the west.
Jake: 这边像这边像一点
Jake: This side seems more like it.
Katrina:  一边进来
Katrina: One side to enter.
Katrina:  哦我知道了
Katrina: Oh, I know.
Katrina:  是一个是这样
Katrina: It's like this.
Katrina:  我们是这样子过来的
Katrina: We came through this way.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina:  嗯就是从这
Katrina: Yeah, from here.
Katrina:  那我们转一会就进去了
Katrina: Let's turn around for a bit and then go in.
Katrina:  差不多在这个位置
Katrina: Around this spot.
Lucia: 所以这俩确实是一个公园
Lucia: So, these two are actually one park.
Lucia: 只不过有一个北关大道
Lucia: Just separated by Beiguan Avenue.
Lucia: 把他们俩隔开了
Lucia: It divides them.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  那能出去吗
Katrina: Can we go out?
Jake: 这出去是这是吗
Jake: Is this the way out?
Jake: 这是啥玩意
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 啥也不是
Jake: Nothing at all.
Jake: 20号是谁
Jake: Who's number 20?
Jake: 南站道北站道
Jake: South station, north station.
Jake: 再转回去买水走
Jake: Let's turn back and buy some water.
Lucia: 好热呀
Lucia: It's so hot.
Lucia: 蝴蝶开会哈哈
Lucia: The butterflies are having a meeting, haha.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 走开这里是蝴蝶的盛宴哈哈哈
Tasha: Move away, this is the butterflies' feast, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 我们去买水吧
Jake: Let's go buy some water.
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 买到就是绕到入口的地方
Jake: Buy some and then circle back to the entrance.
Tasha: 刚刚你们没看到我的那个地方
Tasha: You guys didn't see my spot earlier.
Lucia: 蝴蝶又补气哈哈哈
Lucia: The butterflies are recharging, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈蝴蝶应该怎么抓呀
Jake: Haha, how should we catch butterflies?
Jake: 拿网抓是吧
Jake: With a net, right?
Lucia: 啊没有
Lucia: Oh, no.
Jake: 没有我现在
Jake: No, I mean now...
Lucia: 我们是在说怎么形容
Lucia: We were talking about how to describe it.
Jake: 哈哈这个是蝴蝶诱捕器
Jake: Haha, this is a butterfly trap.
Lucia: 对对对对对
Lucia: Exactly, exactly.
Jake: 你们就过来了是吧
Jake: You just came over, right?
Lucia: 我们三个是蝴蝶
Lucia: The three of us are butterflies.
Lucia: 这是诱捕器
Lucia: This is the trap.
Jake: oh
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 走吧我们绕回去
Jake: Let's go, we'll circle back.
Tasha: 今天怎么不穿绿色
Tasha: Why aren't you wearing green today?
Tasha: 你已经被踢出我们蝴蝶工会了
Tasha: You're kicked out of our butterfly guild.
Lucia: 哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我还有我还有一个护士
Tasha: Hahaha, I still have, I still have a nurse.
Jake: 我还有我还有一个裤子是绿色
Jake: I still have, I still have a pair of green pants.
Lucia: 这次出来好像没带绿衣服
Lucia: Seems like I didn't bring any green clothes this time.
Lucia: 早知道应该带一条绿裙子
Lucia: I should have brought a green dress.
Jake: 蝴蝶有绿色的吗
Jake: Are there green butterflies?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake: 嗯好像不太有
Jake: Hmm, doesn't seem like there are many.
Lucia: 好像不太有
Lucia: Doesn't seem like there are many.
Tasha: 是那个穿着一身绿裙子啊
Tasha: Is that the one wearing a green dress?
Jake: 精品蝴蝶
Jake: Premium butterfly.
Lucia: 对对那个小人是绿色的
Lucia: Yes, yes, that little figure is green.
Lucia: 小人身边那蝴蝶好像也还真是绿色的
Lucia: The butterfly near the figure really is green too.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 官方好像每个人格都给出来三个形象
Alice: The official seems to give each character three images.
其他人： 哦对一个男的一个女的嗯还有
Others: Oh yeah, one male, one female, and there's also...
Tasha: 还有个什么
Tasha: And what else?
Lucia: 还有一个中性形象就是
Lucia: And a neutral image, like...
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 还有南蝴蝶
Tasha: And a male butterfly.
Tasha: 就是跟我们穿的是不一样的是吧对
Tasha: So it's different from what we're wearing, right? Yeah.
Lucia: 对就是他的形象会有变化
Lucia: Yes, its image can change.
Lucia: 但是代表的都是这个人格
Lucia: But it always represents this character.
Alice: 就平时看见EFP竟然是个女的形象
Alice: Usually, we see EFP as a female image.
Alice: 我一直以为是个
Alice: I always thought it was a...
Alice: 像不像男孩
Alice: Doesn't it look like a boy?
Lucia: 哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Alice: 就快乐小狗好像是女的
Alice: The happy puppy seems to be female.
Alice: 就给出来的
Alice: The one given is...
Alice: 比较通用的
Alice: More common.
Tasha: 那那你的快乐小狗是男的吗
Tasha: So, is your happy puppy a male?
Jake: 啊这个也分吗
Jake: Ah, there's a difference?
Alice: 就是官方是给出来三个形象的
Alice: The official provides three images.
Alice: 一般只就是我们平时用的只
Alice: Usually, we just use the common ones.
Jake: 哦还有
Jake: Oh, there's more.
Alice: 一个是典型的形象
Alice: One is the typical image.
Jake: 型的形象
Jake: Typical image.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Tasha: water water water water water water
Tasha: Water, water, water, water, water, water.
Lucia: 呃不是NTP
Lucia: Uh, not NTP.
Lucia: 是药水是做实验的那个
Lucia: It's a potion for experiments.
Alice: PG是小老头
Alice: PG is the old man.
Lucia: 啊对对
Lucia: Ah, right, right.
Katrina:  前两天测MB
Katrina: Tested MB a couple of days ago.
Alice: ESTJ是尺节尺子
Alice: ESTJ is the ruler, you know.
Lucia: ESTJ我朋友里好像都没有ESTJ
Lucia: I don't think any of my friends are ESTJ.
Katrina:  他上次不是说没有s吗
Katrina: Didn't he say there were no 's' last time?
Katrina:  因为因为我是这两天才变成了s
Katrina: Because I just recently turned into an 's'.
Katrina:  不知道为什么变成
Katrina: Don't know why I changed.
Katrina:  我本来是ENT
Katrina: I used to be ENT.
Katrina:  结果变成了e
Katrina: And then turned into an 'e'.
Katrina:  那就是唯一一个s人了是不是
Katrina: So, am I the only 's' person now?
Jake: 啊你怎么突然变成了s
Jake: How did you suddenly turn into an 's'?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  就是好像在就是来北京前一天测的
Katrina: I tested it the day before coming to Beijing.
Jake: 来北京突然变异了
Jake: Mutated upon arrival in Beijing.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 果然是变异
Jake: Definitely mutated.
Lucia: 你看为什么大家加入你的team都会变
Lucia: You see, why does everyone change when they join your team?
Jake: 一直在变异
Jake: Constantly mutating.
Jake: 好吃的吗
Jake: Is it tasty?
Lucia: 就是本来你说子唐和那个谢冰竹
Lucia: You said Zi Tang and Xie Bingzhu.
Lucia: 都是换了
Lucia: Both changed.
Lucia: 换了发型
Lucia: Changed their hairstyles.
Jake: 噢真的吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 然后然后现在那个
Lucia: And now, someone else...
Jake: 噢OK OK OK
Jake: Oh, OK, OK, OK.
Lucia: 哈哈又有人从n变成了s
Lucia: Haha, someone else turned from 'n' to 's'.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  对我刚开始没嗯
Katrina: At first, I didn't...
Lucia: 雨轩真的从n变成了s吗
Lucia: Did Yuxuan really turn from 'n' to 's'?
Jake: 你们有一个人从屁变成借我导致
Jake: One of you turned from 'p' to 'borrow from me'.
Jake: 能理解哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: I can understand, hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 实话说我这两天已经有点想要变成g
Lucia: To be honest, I've been feeling like turning into 'g' these days.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 因为整个组织的无纪律性
Tasha: Because of the disorganization of the whole group.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 不过也挺好的
Lucia: But it's actually pretty good.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我喜欢一些随机事件发生
Lucia: I like it when random things happen.
Lucia: 就本质上还是很p
Lucia: Essentially, it's still very p.
Jake: 这个太这个太P了
Jake: This is too p.
Jake: 这个太p了
Katrina:  搁哪呢
Katrina: Where is it?
Katrina:  这能这能过去吗
Katrina: Can we get through here?
Lucia: 我觉得我大部分的朋友都是NP
Lucia: I think most of my friends are NP.
Tasha: what is this
Tasha: What is this?
Lucia: 也有这一人
Lucia: There's also this person.
Lucia: 但是少一些
Lucia: But fewer of them.
Katrina:  他说我每一个字母都非常的冷漠
Katrina: He said every letter of mine is very cold.
Lucia: 但是ESTJ这个组合好像
Lucia: But this ESTJ combination seems...
Alice: 看到这样桃
Alice: Seeing such peaches...
Lucia: 好像在我的小伙伴里就关系很好
Lucia: Seems like in my group of friends, the relationship is very good.
Lucia: 就是好到大家互相
Lucia: Good to the point where everyone...
Lucia: 这种MBTA类型的里面好像没有
Lucia: Among these MBTI types, there doesn't seem to be...
Katrina:  但是我闺蜜全是哀人好神奇
Katrina: But all my best friends are INFJ, so amazing.
Katrina:  就是我跟爱人能建立那种长期的关系
Katrina: It’s like I can build long-term relationships with INFJs.
Katrina:  然后呢
Katrina: And then...
Shure:  因为你刚才说你说完这个我感觉
Shure: Because you just said, after you said that, I feel...
Katrina:  我之前一直不明白NAS有啥区别
Katrina: I never understood the difference with NAS before.
Katrina:  我之前一直是ENTJ呃
Katrina: I used to be an ENTJ, uh...
Katrina:  分手那会儿变成了ENFJ
Katrina: After the breakup, I became an ENFJ.
Lucia: i don't see soon i pray my four Polly yeah
Lucia: I don't see soon I pray my four Polly yeah.
Tasha: 这棵树上点了好多蜡烛
Tasha: There are so many candles on this tree.
Jake: 好多中指
Jake: So many middle fingers.
Lucia: 哇好热
Lucia: Wow, it's so hot.
Shure:  想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: Want to talk to you about the universe and the sky.
Shure: 往哪边
Shure: Which way?
Katrina:  反正大体方向应该是往这吧
Katrina: Anyway, the general direction should be this way.
Lucia: 我随机选一条路吧哈哈
Lucia: I'll randomly choose a path then, haha.
Jake: 好好我们听j的
Jake: Alright, alright, we'll listen to J.
Lucia: 啊我们要分分组走了吗哦OK OK
Lucia: Ah, are we splitting into groups now? Oh, OK OK.
Jake: 没有他们在玄悟
Jake: No, they are contemplating.
Jake: 他们做历史的抉择
Jake: They are making a historical decision.
Lucia: 历史的抉择
Lucia: A historical decision.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice: 历史的分岔路口
Alice: At the crossroads of history.
Jake: 走左还是走右啊
Jake: Should we go left or right?
Lucia: 啊哈你这有别的意思吗
Lucia: Huh, do you mean something else by that?
Jake: 没有别的意思哈哈哈
Jake: No, nothing else, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈这招是不是要剪掉啊
Lucia: Haha, should we cut this part?
Shure:  是不是要剪掉啊
Shure: Should we cut this?
Shure:  你不要瞎
Shure: Don't...
Lucia: 这不要瞎问
Lucia: Don't ask random questions.
Shure: 这些放到文本里没有问题
Shure: There's no problem putting this in the script.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 哈哈什么
Jake: Haha, what?
Lucia: 对对确实确实
Lucia: Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Tasha: 什么叫左左还是左右
Tasha: What do you mean by left-left or left-right?
Jake: 没有什么意思就是左
Jake: It doesn't mean anything, just left.
Jake: 向左转还是向右转
Jake: Turn left or turn right.
Shure: 哈哈你是在认真的发吗是吗
Shure: Haha, are you seriously asking that?
Tasha: 对我我没有听懂这个梗
Tasha: Yeah, I didn't get the joke.
Lucia: 其实也没事
Lucia: Actually, it's fine.
Lucia: 这是现在的那个啥也很常见的
Lucia: It's quite common these days.
Jake: 对对是的是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it is.
Lucia: 也不一定非得有什么
Lucia: It doesn't have to mean anything.
Shure:  在那个时期
Shure: Back in those days...
Jake: 在那个时期可能就剪刀石头布
Jake: Back then, it was like rock-paper-scissors.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 一定要再多加两两多补两刀吗
Lucia: Do we need to add a couple more lines?
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 左右
Tasha: Left or right.
Jake: 就是就是一分钟之前
Jake: Like, just a minute ago.
Lucia: 对对对对是这样的
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Jake: 没有别的意思
Jake: No other meaning.
Jake: 对对因为很难选嘛
Jake: Yeah, because it's hard to choose.
Lucia: 因为现在没岔路了
Lucia: Because now there's no fork in the road.
Tasha: 好科普一下
Tasha: Okay, let's explain it.
Jake: 你在录吧
Jake: Are you recording?
Jake: 我看看你的灯
Jake: Let me check your light.
Jake: 哦确实外面看不太清
Jake: Oh, it's hard to see from the outside.
Jake: 但是得看一看好的
Jake: But we need to check, okay.
Tasha: 不在录
Tasha: Not recording.
Shure:  我斜斜的往上看一眼
Shure: I'm glancing up.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 我这个好像红色的灯
Alice: I think my light is red.
Jake: 哦那你你看一下
Jake: Oh, then you, you take a look.
Jake: 是不是快没电了还是怎么的
Jake: Is it almost out of battery or what?
Lucia: 亮好像是还亮着的
Lucia: The light seems to still be on.
Jake: 对红的
Jake: Yeah, it's red.
Jake: 要不就是过热要不就是它过热
Jake: Either it's overheating or it's overheating.
Jake: 它会报警
Jake: It will give a warning.
Alice: 这是有点热了 100%的电
Alice: It's a bit hot, 100% battery.
Lucia: 我手机倒是有点过热
Lucia: My phone is a bit overheated.
Lucia: 我手机电池不行了
Lucia: My phone battery is not working.
Lucia: 现在没电
Lucia: Now it's out of power.
Jake: 100%的电你插电呢是吧
Jake: 100% battery, you plugged it in, right?
Alice: yes我一直在充
Alice: Yes, I've been charging it.
Tasha: 我们用了这么久还这么多电
Tasha: We've used it for so long and still so much battery.
Jake: 他插电了
Jake: He plugged it in.
Alice: 因为我在一直充电
Alice: Because I've been charging it.
Jake: 那就合理
Jake: That makes sense.
Jake: 那就是过热
Jake: Then it's overheating.
Jake: 应该在阴凉地多走一走
Jake: It should walk more in the shade.
Jake: 降降温
Jake: Cool it down.
Alice: 有点烫烫的嘞
Alice: It's a bit hot.
Jake: 降降温
Jake: Cool it down.
Alice: 小蝴蝶
Alice: Little butterfly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  有人要滚一圈吗
Shure: Anyone want to roll around?
Jake: 算了
Jake: Forget it.
Jake: 等不录的话你可以滚下去
Jake: If we're not recording, you can roll down.
Shure:  我说眼镜看好我我给你
Shure: I'll keep an eye on the glasses for you.
Lucia: 你把眼镜放到这录着你自己滚下去
Lucia: You put the glasses here and record yourself rolling down.
Shure:  算了别污染数据集了
Shure: Forget it, don't pollute the dataset.
Shure:  然后它以为人类的行动方式有一个是滚
Shure: Otherwise, it would think one of the human actions is rolling.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Jake: 就是他
Jake: It's him.
Lucia: 这是早早期人类撒欢的珍贵记录
Lucia: This is a precious record of early humans having fun.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 就是从此以后就是
Jake: From now on,
Jake: 呃如果一个人想到那边
Jake: If someone wants to go there,
Jake: 然后就会Rick man的一个滚下去的做法
Jake: They'll roll down like Rick man.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈这样效
Jake: Hahaha, just like that.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Lucia: 这样效率更高
Lucia: This way is more efficient.
Jake: 率更高哈哈哈
Jake: More efficient, haha.
Lucia: 这是人工智障吧这是
Lucia: Is this artificial stupidity?
Jake: 人工智障那就是
Jake: That's artificial stupidity.
Shure:  因为你看咱们刚才走了一个陡坡
Shure: Because you see, we just walked up a steep slope.
Shure:  然后咱们走的时间可能就是很慢
Shure: And the time we took was really slow.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  这条路呢
Shure: This path...
Shure:  我从这到那个下坡滚这时间更快了
Shure: If I roll down this slope, the time will be quicker.
Lucia: 啊所以
Lucia: Ah, so...
Lucia: 当给出的指令是计算最快路线的时候
Lucia: When the instruction is to calculate the fastest route...
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 就会滚
Lucia: It would roll.
Shure:  一直以为
Shure: Always thought...
Tasha: 啊就会走这里
Tasha: Ah, it would walk here.
Tasha: 走超进道了
Tasha: It took a shortcut.
Jake: 哎抄近道然后走的话晚上他就给我
Jake: Taking a shortcut and walking, at night, it would give me...
Alice: 高德地图不管我能不能过去
Alice: Gaode Maps doesn't care if I can pass.
Alice: 反正他就给我一个穿墙的选项
Alice: It just gives me an option to go through walls.
Alice: 是不是也是这样的
Alice: Isn't it just like that?
Jake: 穿墙 这不行
Jake: Going through walls? That's not possible.
Lucia: 那个应该是他数据没及时更新
Lucia: That's probably because its data wasn't updated in time.
Lucia: 就是他不知道那分上
Lucia: It doesn't know that point.
Jake: 对这是不够智能
Jake: Yeah, it's not smart enough.
Jake: 就是滚下去是可以实现的
Jake: Rolling down is achievable.
Jake: 穿墙是不可实现的
Jake: Going through walls is not.
Lucia: 你怎么知道
Lucia: How do you know?
Lucia: 他不是想让你把墙砸掉啊
Lucia: Maybe it wants you to break down the wall.
Jake: 哈哈哦哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, oh, hahaha.
Alice: 不管我的死活是吧哈哈哈
Alice: Doesn't care about my life, right? Hahaha.
Alice: 哎在这浇花很方便
Alice: Hey, watering flowers here is convenient.
Alice: 直接往这一冲
Alice: Just pour it here directly.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 水顺着就流下去了
Alice: The water flows down smoothly.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  这就是梯田是吗
Shure: Is this a terrace?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 水好亮啊
Alice: The water is so shiny.
Tasha: 波光粼粼
Tasha: It's sparkling.
Lucia: 我们现在是要玩飞花令了吗哈哈
Jake: 来看你们表演
Jake: Let's watch you guys perform.
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 就是你们刚才那个波光粼粼
Lucia: It's just that your "glittering waves" earlier...
Lucia: 我突然想起来昨
Lucia: It suddenly reminded me of...
Lucia: 天的成语接龙
Lucia: Yesterday's idiom game.
Lucia: 然后就想起来飞花令那个提案
Lucia: And then I thought of the "Flying Flowers" proposal.
Alice: 我先来
Alice: I'll go first.
Shure: 这是球队的帽子
Shure: This is the team's hat.
Jake: 这什么球队
Jake: Which team?
Jake: 看一下哦
Jake: Let's take a look.
Jake: 阿塞尔的
Jake: It's from Arsenal.
Lucia: 真的在真的在
Lucia: Really, really.
Lucia: 那个诺坎普买的哈哈
Lucia: Bought it at Camp Nou. Haha
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 成语接龙
Alice: Idiom game.
Lucia: 不过不过
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 我现在不是不是巴萨的球迷了
Lucia: I'm no longer a Barca fan.
Lucia: 也不是不是
Lucia: Not anymore...
Lucia: 就是还没有到路转不是
Lucia: I haven't turned my back on them yet.
Lucia: 也没有到粉转黑的程度
Lucia: And I haven't started hating them either.
Alice: 第一个为所欲为
Alice: The first one, "Do whatever you want."
Lucia: 就粉转路吧
Lucia: Just a fan turned neutral.
Alice: 下一个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Next one, hahaha.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 因为这两年管理太混乱了
Lucia: Because the management has been a mess these past two years.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 为所欲为
Alice: "Do whatever you want."
Lucia: 我正在试图找一个新球队
Lucia: I'm trying to find a new team.
Lucia: 现在目前的备选是阿森纳
Lucia: My current option is Arsenal.
Jake: 阿森纳大炮
Jake: Arsenal's cannon.
Alice: without没c也能是成语吗
Alice: Can "without" be an idiom without "c"?
Jake: 他们在射箭嘛
Jake: Are they shooting arrows?
Jake: 有点厉害
Jake: That's impressive.
Lucia: everywhere
Lucia: Everywhere.
Jake: 前面那两位
Jake: Those two in front.
Tasha: 随便买的
Tasha: Just bought it casually.
Jake: 但前面是有卖东西的地方吗
Jake: But is there a place selling things up ahead?
Tasha: 社区便利店
Tasha: Community convenience store.
Jake: 像吗这个像吗
Jake: Does this look like it?
Jake: 社区便利店确实是
Jake: The community convenience store is indeed
Tasha: 便民
Tasha: Convenient
Shure:  但是他有没有可能在墙那里面呢
Shure: But is it possible that it's inside the wall?
Tasha: 让他伸出来
Tasha: Let it stick out
Tasha: 爷爷给我一瓶水
Tasha: Grandpa, give me a bottle of water
Jake: OK
Jake: 手机连成一串
Jake: String the phones together
Jake: 谢谢您哎呀
Jake: Thank you, oh my
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Yeah, this one
Shure:  这
Shure: This one
Jake: 对啊得有一个包嘛
Jake: Yeah, we need a bag
Katrina:  这是什么花
Katrina: What kind of flower is this?
Shure:  包好沉啊
Shure: The bag is so heavy
Lucia: 哈哈哈我不会说出去的
Lucia: Haha, I won't tell anyone
Katrina:  这我没见过
Katrina: I haven't seen this before
Lucia: 快乐吃瓜哈哈
Lucia: Enjoying the gossip, haha
Alice: 什么鬼
Alice: What the heck
Alice: 魔鬼我错过了什么
Alice: Devil, what did I miss?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 没错过是吧
Lucia: You didn't miss anything, right?
Katrina:  30度
Katrina: 30 degrees
Lucia: 你问微微哈哈
Lucia: Ask Tasha, haha
Tasha: 什么都没有
Tasha: There's nothing
Tasha: 啦啦啦
Tasha: La la la
Katrina:  我还带了加绒卫衣呢
Katrina: I even brought a fleece hoodie
Jake: 这确实出不去对吧
Jake: We really can't get out, right?
Tasha: 便民空间
Tasha: Convenience space
Tasha: 里面没有便民超市
Tasha: There's no convenience store inside
Jake: 那这个空间是干嘛的呢
Jake: Then what's this space for?
Tasha: 类似于那种社区空间
Tasha: It's like a community space
Jake: 打麻将用的
Jake: For playing mahjong
Tasha: 呃也许吧
Tasha: Uh, maybe
Lucia: 还有乒乓球估计
Lucia: And probably ping pong too
Tasha: 读书
Tasha: Reading
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 乒乓球
Tasha: Ping pong
Jake: 那这也
Jake: So this is also
Katrina:  耳朵
Katrina: Ears
Tasha: 哎但这有卖水的门口
Tasha: Hey, but there's a place selling water at the entrance.
Katrina:  那好像能出去
Katrina: It looks like we can get out there.
Katrina:  出去就过来
Katrina: Just go out and come back.
Katrina:  应该这种修的这种道都会用
Katrina: Roads like this are usually usable.
Lucia: 有被晒到
Lucia: Getting some sun here.
Shure:  我们的野餐
Shure: Our picnic.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  我们的野餐就是刚刚在在那个栏杆上
Shure: Our picnic was just over there by the railing.
Shure:  然后吃狮子
Shure: And we ate lions.
Jake: 跟雨一起吃披萨对
Jake: Eating pizza in the rain, right.
Shure:  对然后爆掉一个手串
Shure: Yeah, and then a bracelet broke.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  献祭
Shure: A sacrifice.
Lucia: 啊他说他在说我们的野餐计划
Lucia: Ah, he's talking about our picnic plan.
Lucia: 就是刚才和淤挤
Lucia: Just now, with the puddle.
Tasha: 生态共享
Tasha: Ecological sharing.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 还有第二餐
Jake: And there's a second meal.
Jake: 其实我们还有几个披萨
Jake: Actually, we still have a few pizzas left.
Lucia: 这次喂谁呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Who are we feeding this time, haha.
Tasha: 还有一盒
Tasha: There's one box left.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们还有一盒披萨
Jake: Haha, we still have a box of pizza.
Katrina:  这留当晚饭了
Katrina: Let's save this for dinner.
Lucia: 可是这里没有那个
Lucia: But there's none of that here.
Tasha: 好像是羊肉披萨
Tasha: Seems like it's lamb pizza.
Lucia: 没有那个海鸥耶
Lucia: No seagulls here.
Jake: 北京竟然没有海鸥
Jake: Beijing actually has no seagulls.
Tasha: 北京为什么会有海鸥
Tasha: Why would Beijing have seagulls?
Lucia: 北京也不靠海吧好像
Lucia: Beijing isn't by the sea, right?
Jake: 北京
Jake: Beijing.
Katrina:  我身上穿的就是海鸥
Katrina: I'm wearing seagulls.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dum dum dum dum.
Tasha: 又晒又热
Tasha: It's so sunny and hot.
Lucia: 行我要两个都摘掉我就给他拿下来
Lucia: Okay, I'll take both off and give them to him.
Lucia: 别掉了
Lucia: Don't drop them.
Jake: 你这身上设备挺多
Jake: You've got a lot of gear on you.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 对我带了个耳机
Lucia: Yeah, I'm wearing headphones.
Jake: 对很赛博
Jake: Very cyber.
Lucia: 我已经为了照顾这个眼镜没有戴大
Lucia: I didn't wear the big ones to take care of these glasses.
Tasha: 这是要出去了吗
Tasha: Are we heading out?
Lucia: 戴了头戴耳机了哈哈
Lucia: She put on her headset, haha.
Alice: 啊可以出去
Alice: Ah, we can go out.
Tasha: 已经出去了
Tasha: We're already out.
Tasha: 都没有遇到水
Tasha: Didn't encounter any water.
Jake: 没有水
Jake: No water.
Tasha: 走错路了
Tasha: We took the wrong path.
Jake: 问问看吧是出哪去了
Jake: Let's ask where we ended up.
Jake: 看看地图吧要不
Jake: Or maybe check the map.
Tasha: 公园就采集完毕了吗
Tasha: Are we done collecting in the park?
Jake: 诶诶诶
Jake: Eh, eh, eh.
Lucia: 我们走到那个塔那个那里面了吗
Lucia: Did we get to that tower, inside it?
Jake: 们最好对
Jake: We better have.
Lucia: 是不是没有呀
Lucia: Didn't we?
Lucia: 我我没记得
Lucia: I don't remember.
Lucia: 我有见到那个塔
Lucia: I saw the tower.
Jake: 我其实是在找水但是没找着
Jake: I was actually looking for water but couldn't find any.
Lucia: 保利发展控股竟然在这里
Lucia: Poly Developments is actually here?
Alice: 接水
Alice: Get water.
Alice: 真的吗
Alice: Really?
Lucia: 这PRD不会都是保利的吧
Lucia: Isn't this whole PRD area Poly's?
Jake: 我们这个路走的确实抽象了一点
Jake: We did take a bit of an abstract route.
Jake: 我们在沿河走离这个公园越来越远
Jake: We're walking along the river, getting further from the park.
Lucia: 啊哈嗯
Lucia: Ah, hmm.
Jake: 哈哈哈可以这就是
Jake: Haha, this is...
Lucia: 这个是符合符合计划的吗嗯
Lucia: Is this according to the plan?
Jake: 可能没有特别符合
Jake: Maybe not exactly.
Lucia: 那我们怎么办
Lucia: What should we do then?
Jake: 那我们在可能绕回去吧
Jake: We might need to loop back.
Lucia: 我们修正一下路线
Lucia: Let's adjust our route.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 可恶路线选错了
Tasha: Darn, we picked the wrong route.
Shure:  像我们去超市的时候再买水
Shure: Maybe we can buy water at the supermarket later.
Jake: 那可能有点这边真的没有水哈
Jake: That might be, there's really no water here.
Jake: 这可是居民区的呀
Jake: This is a residential area.
Jake: 我们已经
Jake: We've already...
Shure:  要走到小区里
Shure: ...got to walk into the community.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  刚那便利店
Katrina: That convenience store...
Katrina:  只能从这出去再绕回去
Katrina: ...we have to go out and loop back.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes
Jake: 对我们偏离路线偏离了一公里
Jake: Yeah, we deviated from the route by one kilometer
Jake: 哈哈哈没有关系没有关系
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay, it's okay
Shure:  没有关系
Shure: It's okay
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure:  一定是在J人的计划中吧
Shure: This must be part of J's plan
Katrina:  yeah
Katrina: Yeah
Lucia: 一定有他的道理
Lucia: There's definitely a reason for it
Jake: 没问题
Jake: No problem
Alice: 那我们走水路吧
Alice: Then let's take the water route
Alice: 感觉那里面凉快
Alice: It feels cooler in there
Lucia: 我们可以沿着它走
Lucia: We can walk along it
Jake: 我们可以过个马路得了哪都来了
Jake: We can cross the street, we've come this far anyway
Alice: 哎都来了
Alice: Yeah, we've come this far
Lucia: 那就我走到保利的那块地坪上去
Lucia: Then I'll walk to the concrete area at Poly
Jake: 对面是不是也没有什么
Jake: Is there nothing on the other side too?
Jake: 还是那就走水陆会
Jake: Or should we just take the water and land route
Jake: 还是这边阴凉一点
Jake: It's still cooler on this side
Lucia: 上说太阳现在是这个方向
Lucia: The sun is in this direction now
Lucia: 所以可能都不是很阴凉
Lucia: So it's probably not very shady anywhere
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright then
Alice: 我们不能游过去吗
Alice: Can't we swim across?
Jake: 可以
Jake: We can
Shure:  但眼镜不防水
Shure: But my glasses aren't waterproof
Jake: 我们
Jake: We
Lucia:我帮你保管眼睛
Lucia: I'll keep your glasses safe
Alice: 谁会游泳呢
Alice: Who can swim anyway?
Lucia: 其实我会哈哈
Lucia: Actually, I can hahaha
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go
Jake: 回头
Jake: Turn back
Jake: 回到起点
Jake: Back to the starting point
Shure: 我们可以不回去从这再去下一个地点不也行吗
Shure: Can't we just go to the next spot from here instead of going back?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Katrina:  回到七天院
Katrina: Back to the Seven Days Inn
Katrina:  要不要先买水再回到起点
Katrina: Should we buy some water first before going back?
Jake: 也可以水在这附近还是
Jake: We could, is there water nearby or
Katrina:  水就刚刚那个便利店
Katrina: The convenience store we just passed
Katrina:  只是从这绕绕出去一下
Katrina: Just go around from here and go out.
Jake: 好那绕一圈
Jake: Okay, then go around once.
Jake: 再绕一圈
Jake: And go around again.
Jake: 把小区给建了
Jake: Build the neighborhood.
Shure:  但是小区我i们没有那什么能进吗
Shure: But we don't have anything to get into the neighborhood, do we?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 刷脸不可以吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can't we just use facial recognition? Hahaha
Jake: 咱就说要买水
Jake: We'll just say we're buying water.
Jake: 光天化日之下我们能干什么
Jake: What can we do in broad daylight?
Katrina:  应该能进去吧这边
Katrina: We should be able to get in here, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 拍VLOG吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Just filming a VLOG, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哎呀干嘛
Lucia: Oh my, what are you doing?
Alice: 吓死我了
Alice: You scared me to death.
Lucia: 对不起
Lucia: Sorry.
Alice: 没有没有没有
Alice: No, no, no.
Alice: 我在想事情
Alice: I was just thinking about something.
Lucia: 在想什么呀
Lucia: What are you thinking about?
Alice: 我在想我五一怎么回家
Alice: I was thinking about how to get home for May Day.
Alice: 要不要回家
Alice: Whether I should go home or not.
Alice: 你呢
Alice: What about you?
Lucia: 我应该又回吧
Lucia: I should go back too.
Lucia: 我五一安排在家躺着
Lucia: I'll just lay around at home for May Day.
Lucia: 因为五一放假出去玩的人太多了
Lucia: Because there are too many people going out during the May Day holiday.
Alice: 对我也是
Alice: Yeah, me too.
Alice: 我就在想
Alice: I was just thinking,
Alice: 回家躺跟在寝室躺
Alice: Is there any real difference between lying at home and lying in the dorm?
Alice: 有什么本质上特别的区别吗
Alice: Is there any essential difference?
Tasha: 我觉得这就会有便利店
Tasha: I think there will be a convenience store here.
Jake: 对这边一条街的超市前面
Jake: Yeah, in front of the supermarket on this street.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 我看到了两个字
Jake: I saw two words.
Jake: 超市对
Jake: Supermarket, right.
Tasha: 超市好
Tasha: Supermarket, good.
Tasha: 你眼睛真好我看不见
Tasha: You have good eyes, I can't see it.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 你不是近视吗
Tasha: Aren't you nearsighted?
Jake: 带隐形眼镜的呀
Jake: I'm wearing contact lenses.
Jake: 有超市好强啊
Jake: Having a supermarket is awesome.
Tasha: 看见
Tasha: I see.
Lucia: 然后呢
Lucia: And then?
Lucia: 我每次放假的时候都更喜欢哈哈
Lucia: Every time I have a holiday, I prefer to just chill at home.
Lucia: 家里蹲
Lucia: Be a homebody.
Tasha: 你骂我了
Tasha: You insulted me.
Jake: 为什么是我
Jake: Why me?
Tasha: 你跟我说过话
Tasha: You talked to me.
Jake: 啊哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 羽毛球
Jake: Badminton.
Lucia: 清明节吗
Lucia: During Qingming Festival?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Alice: 野营的人比树还多
Alice: There were more campers than trees.
Alice: 我那天快被吓死了
Alice: I was almost scared to death that day.
Alice: 但那天天还蛮好的
Alice: But the weather was pretty good that day.
Alice: 我们去逛了
Alice: We went for a walk.
Alice: 不对我们去放风筝了
Alice: No, we flew kites instead.
Lucia: 妈耶
Lucia: Oh my.
Alice: 你最近会在北京待吗
Alice: Will you be staying in Beijing recently?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我要是在北京待我还得专门租个房子
Lucia: If I stay in Beijing, I’ll have to rent a place.
Jake: 秒啊竟然有个大超市
Jake: Wow, there's a big supermarket.
Katrina:  喵喵喵喵
Katrina: Meow meow meow meow.
Alice: 那你是这个结束之后先回家还是
Alice: So will you go home after this or...?
Lucia: 我现在是这样想的
Lucia: That's what I'm thinking now.
Katrina:  我喝水呢
Katrina: I'm drinking water.
Lucia: 不过我也有可能需要在北京办点事情
Lucia: But I might need to handle some things in Beijing too.
Lucia: 所以不是很确定
Lucia: So it's not very certain.
Katrina:  我喝营养快线
Katrina: I'm drinking Nutritional Express.
Alice: 有无怡宝有
Alice: Do they have Yibao Water?
其他人：这个报销吗
Others: Is this reimbursable?
Jake: 呃可以报吧
Jake: Uh, I think so.
Jake: 你们扫吧
Jake: Just scan it.
Alice: 有人喝矿泉水吗
Alice: Anyone want mineral water?
Jake: 嗯不喝
Jake: Hmm, no thanks.
Lucia: 好多种类
Lucia: So many options.
Lucia: 我选择恐惧症犯了
Lucia: I'm getting choice paralysis.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 一起付
Jake: Let's pay together.
Lucia: 我要这个
Lucia: I want this one.
Alice: 好你要哪个
Alice: Okay, which one do you want?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 帮我选一个吧
Jake: Help me choose one.
Lucia: 你有选择恐惧症吗
Lucia: Do you have decision anxiety?
Jake: 谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia: 不选哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Don't choose, hahaha.
Jake: 这个就算了
Jake: Forget about this one.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake: 我知道我可以say no
Jake: I know I can say no.
Jake: 我不能我不知道这个吧
Jake: I can't, I don't know about this one.
Alice: 这个吧
Alice: How about this one?
Jake: 这个也可以
Jake: This one works too.
Jake: 这个可以谢谢您
Jake: This is fine, thank you.
Lucia: 我觉得值得试试东鹏特饮
Lucia: I think it's worth trying Dongpeng Special Drink.
Lucia: 困了累了喝东鹏特饮
Lucia: Tired and sleepy? Drink Dongpeng Special Drink.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 啊哎
Lucia: Ah hey.
Lucia: 怎么能一样啊
Lucia: How can it be the same?
Lucia: 你知道薇薇选的是什么
Lucia: Do you know what Tasha chose?
Lucia: 说不定我们三个都一样
Lucia: Maybe all three of us chose the same.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Oh yeah.
Jake: 薇薇还没选
Jake: Tasha hasn't chosen yet.
Lucia: 他拿来尖叫
Lucia: He brought it to scream.
其他人：123456
Others: 123456.
其他人：32一共
Others: 32 in total.
Jake: 啊扫的这么快
Jake: Wow, you scanned so fast.
其他人：32 35
Others: 32, 35.
Jake:  OK行
Jake: Okay, deal.
Jake: 我怎么付你
Jake: How do I pay you?
Jake: 我扫这个行
Jake: Can I scan this?
其他人：微信收款22.5元
Others: WeChat payment, 22.5 yuan.
Jake: 35
Jake: 35.
其他人：35
Others: 35.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 呃走
Jake: Uh, let's go.
其他人：微信收款35元
Others: WeChat payment, 35 yuan.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 一个7新币的水
Jake: A 7 SGD water.
Jake: 哈哈哈也可以
Jake: Hahaha, that's fine too.
Lucia: 这个7 新币吗
Lucia: This is 7 SGD?
Jake: 没有就是花了35嘛
Jake: No, I just spent 35.
Lucia: 花了35哦
Lucia: You spent 35?
Jake: 相当于我买了一个七新币的水
Jake: It's like I bought a 7-dollar water.
Jake: 也不是不不常见
Jake: It's not that uncommon.
Jake: 哈哈哈就是
Jake: Haha, just saying.
Shure:  怎么说下一站吗
Shure: So, what's the next stop?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Katrina:  回到起点
Katrina: Back to the starting point.
Katrina:  下一站去哪
Katrina: Where's the next stop?
Katrina:  要不直接在这打车也行
Katrina: Or we could just take a cab here.
Jake: 也行啊下一站去哪啊
Jake: That's fine too. Where's the next stop?
Shure:  我们找找个好打车的地
Shure: Let's find a place where it's easier to get a cab.
Alice: 买什么调料跟什么肉啥来着
Alice: What spices and meat do we need to buy again?
Shure:  这这应该不好打车
Shure: This place might be hard to get a cab.
Jake: 呃不好意思
Jake: Uh, sorry.
Jake: 去哪买啊
Jake: Where do we buy it?
Shure:  找一个大一点的
Shure: Let's find a bigger place.
Shure:  上张超吧还是
Shure: Should we go to a supermarket?
Jake: 好啊
Jake: Sure.
Alice: 有没有那种什么食材
Alice: Do they have those wholesale food markets?
Alice: 批发
Alice: Where they sell pre-skewered meat?
Alice: 市场那种直接带串好签的不也行吗
Alice: Wouldn't that work too?
Tasha: 一旦我发起这个话题你就会很认同
Tasha: Once I bring this up, you'll totally agree.
Tasha: 小蝴蝶是这样的
Tasha: Little Butterfly is like that.
Alice: 碳油刷子
Alice: Charcoal and brushes.
Tasha: 嗯很凉快
Tasha: Yeah, it's pretty cool.
Katrina:  这200米居然有个盒马鲜生
Katrina: There's actually a Hema Fresh 200 meters away.
Jake: 一定有点
Jake: There must be.
Shure:  四四四百米
Shure: Four, four, four hundred meters.
Katrina:  400米有个盒马鲜生
Katrina: There's a Hema Fresh 400 meters away.
Jake: 走吧走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  是河马是吗
Katrina: Is it Hema?
其他人：盒马可以把晚饭解决了吧
Others: Hema can solve our dinner, right?
Shure:  走带路
Shure: Let's go, lead the way.
Katrina:  那就盒马
Katrina: Then Hema it is.
Katrina:  直接买那个肉
Katrina: Let's just buy the meat.
Katrina:  然后烤肉
Katrina: And then barbecue.
Jake: 还有对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 那还回公园吗
Tasha: Are we going back to the park then?
Jake: 不回了不回了吧
Jake: Let's not go back.
其他人：不回了不回了
Others: Let's not go back.
Jake: 好绿啊
Jake: So green.
Jake: 哼哼
Jake: Hmph.
Jake: 不能更绿了
Jake: It can't get greener.
Jake: 好吧啊
Jake: Alright, okay.
Tasha: 啊不能更绿了好
Tasha: Ah, it can't get greener, alright.
Jake: 不能更绿了不能更绿了
Jake: It can't get greener, it can't get greener.
Jake: 和小女人合个影
Jake: Let's take a photo with the little lady.
Tasha: 不行眼镜不行
Tasha: No, my glasses, no.
Tasha: 怎么这么晒
Tasha: Why is it so sunny?
Jake: 好好太绿了
Jake: Okay, okay, it's too green.
Tasha: 好哈哈哈
Tasha: Okay, hahaha.
Tasha: 我要不要帮你把水放到书包里
Tasha: Should I help you put the water in your bag?
Jake: 不要我还要喝
Jake: No, I still need to drink it.
Tasha: 这样就可以解放你的双手了
Tasha: This way, your hands will be free.
Jake: 啊我为什么要解放双手
Jake: Ah, why do I need my hands free?
Tasha: 你想要手上拿的东西是吗
Tasha: Do you want to hold something else in your hands?
Jake: 因为我可以
Jake: Because I can.
Jake: 没有我还一会还要喝呢
Jake: No, I still need to drink it later.
Tasha: 哦我还以为你是喜欢手上拿东西
Tasha: Oh, I thought you just like holding things in your hands.
Jake: 哦没有没有
Jake: Oh, no, no.
Tasha: 口
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈怎么了
Jake: Hahaha, what's up?
Tasha: 因为要是帮你把水放到你的书包里
Tasha: Because if I put the water in your bag,
Tasha: 我就可以把我这也偷偷塞进去
Tasha: I can secretly put mine in too.
Tasha: 如果你喜欢手上拿东西
Tasha: If you like holding things.
Jake: 哦哦哦那你不喝
Jake: Oh, oh, so you don't want to drink?
Tasha: 就可以手上再多拿一瓶
Tasha: Then you can hold another bottle.
Jake: 你不喝了是吧
Jake: You don't want to drink, right?
Tasha: 嗯没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha: 是的是的
Tasha: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 呵呵没关系
Tasha: Hehe, it's okay.
Jake: 哎呀通州公安局
Jake: Oh, Tongzhou Police Station.
Jake: 大家想想大家想想有没有要要报案的
Jake: Everyone think, everyone think, does anyone need to file a report?
Jake: 顺便就哈哈哈哈
Jake: While we're at it, hahaha.
Tasha: 我迟到了
Tasha: I'm late.
Tasha: i'm late
Jake: late what
Jake: Late for what?
Jake: 哇好快好牛啊
Jake: Wow, so fast, so impressive.
Jake: 一切都在掌握之中
Jake: Everything is under control.
Jake: 啊不用不用
Jake: Ah, no need, no need.
Jake: 逛逛商场
Jake: Let's walk around the mall.
Alice: 风云再起
Alice: Here we go again.
Jake: 这个商场档次如何
Jake: How's the quality of this mall?
Tasha: 那我们要不要去看一下风云再起
Tasha: Should we check out "Here we go again"?
Alice: 你要抓娃娃
Alice: You want to play the claw machine?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 风云再起是什么
Jake: What's "Here we go again"?
Lucia: 呃呃看起来像健身俱乐部
Lucia: Uh, it looks like a fitness club.
Jake: 抓娃娃的
Jake: It's for the claw machine.
Jake: 行啊那抓会啊
Jake: Sure, let's give it a try then.
Alice: 不是是那种打电动的
Alice: No, it's for playing arcade games.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 可以抓吗哈
Lucia: Can we win something, haha?
Jake: 抓走
Jake: Let's go win something.
Tasha: 走
Tasha: Let's go.
Tasha: 什么不行
Tasha: What do you mean "no"?
Jake: 什么不行
Jake: What do you mean "no"?
Jake: 都行都行
Jake: Everything's fine.
Alice: 他们在另一个话题
Alice: They're on another topic.
Jake: 哦什么不行啊
Jake: Oh, what do you mean "no"?
Tasha: 哦哈
Tasha: Oh, haha.
Jake: 什么不行
Jake: What do you mean "no"?
Tasha: 不知道我以为风云再起不行
Tasha: I don't know, I thought "Here we go again" was a no-go.
Tasha: 那他就别玩哈哈
Tasha: Then he shouldn't play, haha.
Jake: 风云再起为啥不行
Jake: Why is "Here we go again" a no-go?
Lucia: 我觉得看起来像啊
Lucia: I think it looks like it.
Lucia: 那有可能是游戏厅旁边写了一个游戏
Lucia: Maybe it's a game hall with a sign saying "game".
Tasha: 肯定是游戏厅都已经
Tasha: It's definitely a game hall.
Lucia: 游啊我的儿子怎么在这啊
Lucia: Oh, my son is here.
Alice: 我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: My son is here.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 哦你的儿子哦
Jake: Oh, your son, oh.
Lucia: 哦哇儿子
Lucia: Oh wow, son.
Alice: 我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: My son is here.
Jake: 哎你
Jake: Hey you.
Jake: 你和他
Jake: You and him.
Tasha: 适配是吗
Tasha: Are they a match?
Jake: 哈哈颜色挺到位是吧
Jake: Haha, the colors match well, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯火锅
Tasha: Mm-hmm, hotpot.
Tasha: 呃不是烧烤
Tasha: Uh, not barbecue.
Tasha: 让AI采集一下
Tasha: Let AI gather some data.
Tasha: 破解一下娃娃机的秘密
Tasha: To crack the secret of the claw machine.
Lucia: 那个好像是编好程的
Lucia: That seems to be pre-programmed.
Lucia: 就是他
Lucia: It's like...
Lucia: 隔几次就会有一次抓得比较紧的时候
Lucia: Every few tries, it grabs tightly once.
Jake: 哎我们先
Jake: Hey, let's first...
Jake: 我我们我们先在商场里边整点活吧
Jake: Let's first do something in the mall.
Jake: 先晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's wander around first.
Jake: 然后再买东西再提走对
Jake: Then we can buy things and take them with us, right?
Shure:  我们去小米买点电电池哈哈哈
Shure: Let's go to Xiaomi and buy some batteries, haha.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  好特卖好特卖好特卖好特卖
Katrina: Great sale, great sale, great sale, great sale.
Lucia: 对对对因为比较便宜
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, because it's cheaper.
Jake: 好好特卖是什么
Jake: Wait, what's a great sale?
Katrina:  便宜货呵呵呵
Katrina: Cheap stuff, hehe.
Lucia: 那个特价店对对对
Lucia: That discount store, yeah.
Jake: 哦哦好
Jake: Oh, oh, got it.
Katrina:  就是他都是那种临期的
Katrina: They're all about-to-expire items.
Jake: 等等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait a second.
Katrina:  但是对于我们就很熟
Katrina: But for us, it's really familiar.
Jake: 我我们好像还没对齐
Jake: We haven't aligned yet.
Jake: 现在甚至现在
Jake: Even now.
Jake: 对一下把把把他叫过来来来来
Jake: Align it, call him over, come on, come on.
Shure:  哦我们出发的时候忘看这个
Shure: Oh, we forgot to check this when we left.
Jake: 对没看这个东西对好
Jake: Yeah, didn't check this thing, okay.
Jake: 3:47 行
Jake: 3:47, got it.
Katrina:  那我要去买包卫生巾
Katrina: I need to buy a pack of sanitary pads.
Lucia: 他居然挂在外面
Lucia: He actually hung it outside.
Lucia: 顺手拿出我的魔法剪刀
Lucia: I casually took out my magic scissors.
Jake: 抓一次多少钱
Jake: How much is one try?
Lucia: 现在可能两一般两块钱吧好像
Lucia: Now it's probably two, usually two yuan, I think.
Lucia: 反正感觉他这玩意在涨价所以就
Lucia: Anyway, it feels like the price is increasing, so...
Jake: 哦哦看看看看看看
Jake: Oh, oh, let's see, let's see.
Katrina:  3块钱一次
Katrina: Three yuan per try.
Lucia: 3块钱 3都3块钱了
Lucia: Three yuan? It's three yuan now?
Lucia: 北京已经这个行情了吗
Lucia: Has Beijing reached this rate?
Jake: 这么贵
Jake: So expensive.
Jake: 100个币是什么意思
Jake: What does 100 coins mean?
Jake: 100个币抓几次
Jake: How many times can you play with 100 coins?
Alice: 他们有的是3个币
Alice: Some of them cost 3 coins.
Alice: 有的5个币
Alice: Some cost 5 coins.
Alice: 这种抓一次
Alice: This one is 1 play per coin.
Tasha: 30次吧
Tasha: About 30 times.
Lucia: 30次大概
Lucia: Around 30 times, I guess.
Jake: 那我100个币你们你们自由分配
Jake: Alright, I'll give you 100 coins and you can distribute them freely.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  好吧那就微信购
Katrina: Okay, let's buy through WeChat.
Jake: 好吧好行
Jake: Alright, sounds good.
Katrina:  是不是便宜点
Katrina: Isn't it cheaper?
Shure:  呼呼
Shure: Haha.
Jake: 怎么哦好行
Jake: How's that? Okay, let's do it.
Katrina:  就扫这个嘛那89
Katrina: Just scan this, right? Then it's 89.
Lucia: 那个微信购币好像89100币
Lucia: I think buying coins through WeChat is 89 for 100 coins.
Katrina:  耶老板万岁哈哈
Katrina: Long live the boss, haha!
Shure:  若每人夸一句杨哥好帅
Shure: If everyone compliments Jake, saying he’s handsome.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  付款的瞬间最帅
Katrina: The moment he pays is when he's the most handsome.
Alice: 有那个大众点评哎
Alice: Look, there's a group buying option.
Alice: 不对那叫啥来着团购
Alice: No, wait, what's it called? Groupon.
Jake: 100个币889是吧
Jake: 100 coins for 89, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 这个会不会便宜一些
Tasha: Wouldn't that be cheaper?
Shure:  应该差不多耶
Shure: It should be about the same.
Jake: 就这样吧
Jake: Let's go with that.
Jake: 够还行
Jake: That's enough, it's fine.
Katrina:  嗯然后再哇
Katrina: Hmm, and then wow.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Jake: 哦不然还得剪是吧
Jake: Oh, otherwise we have to cut it, right?
Jake: 又是一个离谱的数据
Jake: Another ridiculous number.
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina:  84 他这89
Katrina: 84, it's 89 here.
Katrina:  应该差不多吧
Katrina: Should be about the same.
Katrina:  老板觉得5块钱不是钱
Katrina: The boss thinks 5 bucks is nothing.
Jake: 他动了
Jake: He moved.
其他人：会不会有哥码然后你给他
Others: Will there be a code, and then you give it to him?
Shure:  啊你需要点一下对哦对
Shure: Ah, you need to click it, right, oh right.
Lucia: 好神奇
Lucia: So amazing.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Alice: 来吧来吧来吧
Shure:  来吧来吧
Tasha: 来吧来吧
Jake: 来吧
Alice: 一人抓两把得了
Lucia: 是多少个啊
Katrina:  你会抓娃娃吗
Shure:  开玩笑高玩好吗
Tasha: 玩笑
Lucia: 123456789
Jake: 我我们我们也抓去
Jake: 哈哈哈我们也抓吧
Jake: 你你我看你我我拿拿俩吧
Alice: 我们一起抓吧
Alice: 啊我不怎么玩
Jake: 哎对可以啊可以啊你可以
Jake: 没事没事没事没事找我领就好
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: 出师不利的
Tasha: 我带你去玩一个
Jake: 走
Jake: 抓什么呀
Jake: 是不是不只抓娃娃呀
Jake: 别的
Lucia: 对别的也可以
Alice: 这种项目都可以
Jake: OK OK多久没回猫了
Lucia: 您是多久没回国了
Jake: 哈哈哈真真没来过这些地方
Alice: 或者你去玩跳舞机什么也可以
Lucia: 你给我一种至少10年没回国的感觉
Alice: 来上去吧
Jake: 哎这那爵士鼓
Lucia: 哎 95
Lucia: 这可以让修硕来玩
Jake: 对对
Jake: 抓什么呀
Tasha: 我其实想玩那个
Tasha: 但好多人呀
Jake: 这是浪费了我一个币子是吧
Jake: 哈哈哈那那边有那个架子鼓
Jake: Hahaha, there's a drum set over there.
Alice: 三个吧
Alice: Three, right?
Shure:  啊有吗
Shure: Oh really?
Jake: 那边架子鼓
Jake: The drum set over there.
Jake: 围观你打一圈呗
Jake: Let's gather around and watch you play.
Shure:  来一波吧
Shure: Let's go for it.
Jake: 那边
Jake: Over there.
Shure:  这也是难得素材了
Shure: This is some rare material.
Jake: 这行吗这设备够灵玩吗
Jake: Is this okay? Is this equipment sensitive enough?
Shure:  可以可以可以可以
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's fine.
Jake: 可以是吧
Jake: It's okay, right?
Jake: 等会我把大家都叫过来
Jake: Wait a sec, I'll call everyone over.
Jake: 你先等会
Jake: Just wait a bit.
Alice: 给你拍个背面照可以吗
Alice: Can I take a picture of your back?
Jake: 雨轩呢
Jake: Where's Yuxuan?
Jake: 哎雨轩呢
Jake: Hey, where's Yuxuan?
Jake: 不知道去好好找他一下
Jake: I don't know, go find him.
其他人：那我去找一下
Others: I'll go look for him.
Jake: 我我去围观
Jake: I'll go watch.
Jake: 围围观那谁
Jake: Watch who?
Jake: 打架子鼓
Jake: Playing the drums.
Jake: 什么OK OK
Jake: What? OK, OK.
Lucia: 没事又绕过来了我说
Lucia: It's fine, I circled back, I said.
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  4个币子
Shure: Four tokens.
Jake: 4个币的
Jake: Four tokens?
Shure:  4个币子好像能打3手吧应该
Shure: Four tokens should give you three plays, I think.
Shure:  这个很赚的
Shure: This is a good deal.
Jake: 四四个壁子
Jake: Four tokens?
Shure:  4个币子
Shure: Four tokens.
Jake: 你要水平高是不是可以连打
Jake: If you're good, can you keep playing continuously?
Shure:  好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it.
Jake: 不知道啊来
Jake: I don't know, come on.
Shure:  不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Jake: 啊给投过了啊行
Jake: Ah, you put it in, alright.
Alice: 投过了投过了
Alice: Put it in, put it in.
Shure:  啊太丢人了
Shure: Ah, this is so embarrassing.
Jake: 哈哈哈太丢人了
Jake: Hahaha, so embarrassing.
Shure:  game over了
Shure: Game over.
Shure:  我靠哈哈哈
Shure: Damn, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈记录在案
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha, it's on record.
Jake: 首席首席鼓
Jake: Chief, chief drum.
Shure:  不行不行哈哈哈
Shure: No way, no way, hahaha.
Katrina:  但是他一直在边上你知道吗
Katrina: But he's always on the side, you know?
Katrina:  就搞得很心动
Katrina: Makes it really exciting.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 啊这么厉害
Jake: Ah, so impressive.
Katrina:  哈哈装饰屋子有了
Katrina: Haha, now we have decoration for the house.
Jake: 对啊装饰公司
Jake: Yeah, decoration company.
Jake: 挺好挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good, pretty good.
Jake: 你抓了吗
Jake: Did you catch it?
Tasha: 没有币哈哈
Tasha: No coins, haha.
Jake: 啊在哪啊
Jake: Ah, where is it?
Tasha: 在在这里
Tasha: Here, here.
Jake: 你要抓谁
Jake: Who do you want to catch?
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 就是你看下上面的乌龟要比下面的小
Tasha: Look, the turtle on top is smaller than the one below.
Tasha: 只要叠到叠5个
Tasha: You just need to stack five of them.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Tasha: 就可以拿到任意一个奖品
Tasha: Then you can get any prize.
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: That's awesome.
Jake: 嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Jake: 看你表演
Jake: Show me your skills.
Tasha: 你帮我投吧
Tasha: Help me throw.
Tasha: 你想要哪个
Tasha: Which one do you want?
Tasha: 我帮你抓
Tasha: I'll catch it for you.
Jake: 哈哈真的呀
Jake: Haha, really?
Jake: 真的假的哈哈
Jake: Really or not, haha.
Tasha: 假的
Tasha: Fake.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 啊哦
Tasha: Ah, oh.
Tasha: 啊哦你看
Tasha: Ah, oh, look.
Tasha: 这样子就不太好叠了
Tasha: It's hard to stack like this.
Jake: 哦哦我明白了啊
Jake: Oh, I get it now.
Jake: 这就挂了是吧
Jake: So it's game over, right?
Tasha: 你来
Tasha: Your turn.
Tasha: 我其实想要这个
Tasha: I actually want this one.
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake: 要叠5个是吗
Jake: Need to stack five, right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes
Tasha: 他会变大变小开始
Tasha: It can get bigger or smaller, starting now
Tasha: OK你叠好了
Tasha: OK, you've stacked it
Tasha: 第一个
Tasha: The first one
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey
Jake: 这么快
Jake: So fast
Tasha: 这难度本来就是二哈哈废话了
Tasha: This difficulty is like a two, haha, just kidding
Jake: 这就挂了
Jake: It's already game over
Tasha: 你这样不行
Tasha: You can't do it like this
Tasha: 我们再玩最后一次吧没关系
Tasha: Let's play one last time, it's fine
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's fine
Jake:啊这都不行啊再来一次
Jake: Ah, this won't work, let's try again
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah hahaha
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 哦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah hahaha hahaha hahaha hahaha
Jake: 啊啊
Jake: Ah ah
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha hahaha
Jake: 转悠转悠去
Jake: Let's wander around